Instructor: There are
two other array methods, some
and every. These actually aren't
part of ES6, but I feel like
they don't get enough love and
really not enough people know
about them, so I'm going to show
you how to actually use them.
Some and every will check the
data in an array to check if
some of the items meet what
you're looking for or all of the
items meet what you're looking
for. I've got two examples
right here. These are a whole
bunch of ages. Is there at least
one adult in the group? In
Canada, you're 18 and you are
considered an adult, so what we
going to do is to say "const
adultPresent = ages.some."
Why some? Because we want to
find at least one person in the
group that is greater or equal
to 18. Some, it's going to take
a callback, which is age, and we
want to say age is greater than
or equal to 18. What it's
going to do is check every
single one, and as soon as it
hits one of the items that is
true, then it's going to return
true in adultPresent. I'm going
to say console.log(adultPresent)
and we get true. Why? Because it
hits that first one, and says
that we have it. If I have
const younguns equals one, two,
two, five, and we check if there
are any adults in the younguns,
we obviously will get false.
Next we want to know is
everybody old enough to drink in
this group? In Canada, at least,
it's 19 to drink. We want to
check if every single person in
the array meets what we're
looking for. What we're going
to do is say "const allOldEnough =
ages.every age >= 19." If
everybody is greater than or
equal to 19, it will return true,
otherwise we get false. Which is
false. Those are very simple,
but can be very, very handy.